we talked about immigrants we talked
about right the dreamers they they came
to you tooling for a better life for
their children really
well what if Jorge happens to make it
big and I don't know invents a
longer-lasting toilet paper to punish
you
the Republican budget has been out lie
the tax plan we've talked about the
health care plan now we're at the tax
plan and of course a lot of people are
upset in the left's particularly Bernie
Sanders here's my question of the day
have you actually looked at the budget
that's my first question okay what do
you think of the economics what do you
think of the actual policy and then
Bernie's criticisms and proposed
alternative because a lot of people who
watch the show I know a lot of you were
Bernie supporters and then have become
either Trump supporters or all-out
conservatives is that you comment we
want to hear from you let us know what
you think so Bernie Sanders of course
was upset about it and he wrote a piece
in The Guardian which really just reads
like a parody of Bernie Sanders buzz
words just like plastered together like
a collage for a ransom note yeah that's
how I read it in my head
so we'll get to exactly what Donald
Trump's tax plan is but first let's get
to Bernie Sanders his criticism so he
writes the Republican budget which will
likely be debated on the floor of the
Senate this week why did he actually go
to real Bernie no that's not I'm back
back to go back on three is the Robin
Hood principle in Reverse it takes from
those in need and gives to those who are
already living in incredible opulence oh
really
okay before we get to the solid policies
Bernie can you give us any example of a
policy you're actively taking something
from a poor person literally
confiscating their rightfully earned
property and handing it to a wealthy
person is there anything in there to
that effect nothing okay we'll move on
according to the nonpartisan Tax Policy
Center by the end of the decade nearly
80% of the tax benefits of the
Republican plan would go to the top one
percent and forty percent to the top
one-tenth of one percent okay first
let's define the top one percent the
Democrat Party and of course Bernie
Sanders have wanted to raise taxes
dramatically on the top tax bracket
what's that any household earning more
than two and fifty thousand dollars all
right anyone earning more than a quarter
million that's the top tax bracket so
it's important to policy-wise those are
the people we're going to be vilifying
and hitting globally by the way an
income of more than $32,000 puts in the
top one percent so Bernie should be
comfortable giving away ninety percent
of his income absolutely and the top one
percent actually paid nearly 50 percent
of federal income taxes the United
States - even though they only account
for something like two point five
percent of returns filed none of this to
get to the moral case this is just being
pragmatic here when we're talking about
who were vilifying I think that's
important because you like to think of
them as some far-off billionaires no
they kind of do you think of them as
they care anything in others they count
on human greed over two nor fifty
thousand will get exactly to what
Trump's tax plan does in a second like I
said but first Bernie's thoughts this
budget cuts Medicaid by more than 1
trillion over 10 years which would throw
some 50 million Americans off of the
health insurance they currently have
further this budget doesn't Republicans
have not yet attempted to do in their
previous health care legislation that is
to make 473 billion cut to Medicare
that's taken from him cut I think he
wrote yeah a sorry he got that right I
don't want to this is this is really
important one-third of doctors won't
take any new Medicaid patients
the program sucks and they pay a just a
fraction of what private insurers pay
this is an example of where the left
thinks that every problem can be solved
by just throwing more money at it right
we all know that Medicare Medicaid it's
broken it doesn't work everyone
acknowledges the problems the solution
with Bernie Sanders as you can see and
his letter here is just riddled with it
in the Guardian by the way where he
chose to write it is more money
regardless of how broken it is now where
do they get this money the Republican
budget would give the richest family in
America the Walton family of Walmart a
tax cut of up to 52 billion by replacing
the estate tax a tax that only applies
to multimillionaires and billionaires
okay this is where it comes late and
switch that Bernie does okay so here's
what he goes first names a big
billionaire family that is on his base
will undoubtedly love the Walton family
of Walmart saying goodnight to each
other long shot of the house to what now
we know is Walmart Bernie yeah many
people are not aware also Apple they
make phones so he names a big brilliant
heir family which you'll associate with
a state tax it's the death tax you've
heard of that cuz almost everybody when
they talk about it is against the death
tax that's a tax on transferring your
wealth to your children yeah okay if you
make this money you're left have you
read even taxed on it but if you happen
to die and want to give this to your
children as inheritance it's taxed again
and it starts somewhere around five
point five five five point five million
dollars at forty percent rate but at a
forty percent recent now five point five
million is a lot of money to be sure but
it's a far cry from what he wants you to
think with the Waltons or any other
billionaires who he'll name think about
that for a second especially if you look
at if Democrats have there if Bernie has
his way that number is only going to go
down and inflation is going to go up
devaluing the currency so in about
fifteen to twenty years
that'll effectively be to like two
million today if someone could start a
modest portfolio today so in their favor
young 20s and have a million dollars by
the time they retire Oh much more much
much more yeah but certainly two million
dollars again if you adjust for
inflation so let's say let's use five
million dollars let's take someone who
starts a business okay gets gets to the
point where making a quarter million
dollars a year maybe by the time he's 40
he's married his wife works a job they
buy instead of rent they buy used cars
they save their money his wife
while he's 80 he dies at 90 years old
and he wants to pass this on to his kids
five million dollars is not unrealistic
yeah especially since it includes houses
businesses all kinds of everything you
have necessarily have is liquid cash
right and all of your assets are
including and this is a fundamental
difference - between the left and this
is important fun mental difference
between the left and the right this is
why that we throw on this it's anti
American the American Dream is what it's
to make it big to create a better life
for your children everyone came when we
talked about immigrants we talked about
right the dreamers they they came here
to dream for a better life for their
children
really well what if Jorge happens to
make it big and I don't know invents a
longer-lasting toilet paper to punish
you because it's based on this
assumption that the rich people or
automatically horrible human beings
they're bad people rich or bad poor
people are somehow good when the fact is
that's not really true rich people can
be more charitable than sugar people and
sometimes poor people can again this
goes to the collective mindset versus
the individual meant it but the American
Dream is for your children to have a
better life than you now plenty of small
business owners could do this - love
thinks that there needs to be a cap on
the American dream everyone else is
entitled to that not your children for
whom you built it do well but don't do
too well exactly
just stay right in there right and don't
use well-arranged i Bernie Sanders I'm
doing right exactly third third house in
the lake okay goes on to say this budget
says that if you are the second
wealthiest family in America the Koch
brothers oh who do see a tax break of 33
billion but if your working class
student trying to figure out how you
could possibly afford college your dream
of college education could evaporate
along with 8 million of those students
because of more than 100 billion in cuts
to Pell Grants and other student
financial assistance programs again I'd
any politics Koch brothers I also think
they're gonna see a tax break how much
they're paying right now we'll get to
the tax plan in a second interesting
that he brings up school grants and
financial assistance because it's
exactly that kind of artificial cost
inflation that's made college
unaffordable in the first place I don't
have time to go over it remedial go see
our previous video on student loans
here's something to that's really
interesting the burning do you notice in
his criticism he substantiates none of
his claims all he does is talk to the
audience
which is a perfect example of his self
coined democratic socialism and why it's
a scam so look look here we have a
collage just in the same article poll
after poll tells us that the
overwhelming majority of Americans do
not want Congress to cut Medicare and
Medicaid and either the sixty percent of
Americans oppose slashing Medicaid
according to a recent Quinnipiac poll
only twelve percent of American people
believe that the wealthy should receive
a tax cut while sixty percent believe
the wealthy should pay more in taxes the
top one percent is able to rig the
polygamy okay this is the classic
fallacy you see this Bernie doesn't
justify his views or proposals through
data or reality based research and he
never even mentions the word liberty or
freedom unless it's relatable it's
directed at killing a baby doesn't even
turn the equation he simply believes
that it's morally acceptable so long as
the majority of people would vote for it
you would all want that Paul says she
was asking for it now
there was a majority of at one point
there was a majority of people who might
have supported slavery sure the United
States the Nazis came to power delivery
yeah the majority of people voted for
Hugo Chavez in Venezuela 1998 in Islamic
countries that wife-beating is commonly
accepted perfectly legal and also there
are 13 countries where atheists can be
executed for their beliefs wait majority
Muslim native have beliefs well they can
be executed for not accepting the Quran
and Sharia law and Mohammed so finally
let's get to the plan exactly what we're
talking about this is it just he just
tosses to the majority as long as they
want it it's okay
but we've defined the 1% as far as
policy the current top tax rate
individuals now it's thirty nine point
six percent before state Texas in
Trump's proposed plan it would go down
to about thirty five percent but
President Trump being so inconsistent as
he is said that there there may be a
fourth bracket where people could be
taxed more effectively being thirty nine
percent but really what that means is
under the Trump plan the evil evil
wealthy 250,000 earners or more
his case it might be a little bit higher
they'll be paying 4% less in taxes I
mean they'll keep four person about
there or in California negative six
percent state tax and by the way some
middle-class people will go from fifteen
percent down to twelve percent so this
actually benefits a whole lot able then
he talks about of course the corporate
tax rate and this is something that has
always dumb thought or may comment below
if you think that I'm way off the beam
here we have a highest corporate tax
rate in the industrialized world case
number twenty nine percent it's insane
Donald Trump is proposing to cut that
corporate tax rate to twenty percent
which seems radical to you but it would
really just put us in line with the U K
Switzerland and even Bernie's beloved
Iceland Finland Hong Kong has a higher
freedom index rating I know yes sneakers
wrong I know it's a real problem watch
someone factor though it's not true
that's fake news you know you're doing
well until you said that they start with
the feet cheap shoes honey hole denied
what space worm the hole did I jump into
the Scandinavian countries that Bernie
Sanders points to as false examples by
the way of successful socialism and even
the Dayton names prime minister said
stop saying we're social either way the
countries he points to has examples of
successful socialism have tax rates
comparable to the rate that Donald Trump
would want to see is a corporate tax
rate and Bernie Sanders claims that it's
unfair that it's mantras now now why do
they do this because they know that
raising corporate tax rates would
encourage businesses to leave and they
would lose tax revenue not gain it so
they wouldn't be able to pay for all of
their democratic socialism so what
Bernie Sanders wants right is all the
socialist benefits but not even what's
required to pay for it which even in the
Scandinavian socialist countries he
loves this is seen as rudimentary
economics would be a business-friendly
corporate tax rate much more accountable
to Donald Trump's monsters
[Music]
problem solved
you should have never shipped him that
sample mug hey did you like this video
it what you didn't oh you're a cat
person well that makes sense
disregard him and or her /z everyone
else hit the subscribe button and leave
your comment below as to why you like
this video i you know what crazy cat you
can get back you can you can comment
below to as to why you don't like it